I've been getting messages over the past
hour so many people talking about this
art Kelly interview it was his first
interview since he was jailed last month
and our Kelly says the charges of
aggravated criminal sexual abuse are all
lies the singer spoke with Gale for
nearly 80 minutes yesterday he strongly
denied having sex with underage girls or
doing anything illegal in Viana he wants
people to talk about it in this
interview that you'll see only here on
CBS this morning we also asked Kelly
about his rough childhood and his story
or surviving years of sexual abuse he
also discussed how the allegations
against him could affect his personal
life and his career do you spill to
still expect people to buy your music
how do you think your music should sit
with people absolutely I think they
should although a lot of them may not
but like I said I'm really not really
fighting for my career here I'm fighting
for my rights and I'm fighting to have a
relationship with my kids most of all
more than anything I want a relationship
with my kids because I've missed a lot
of years they're like they love me I
love them and they want a relationship
with you on it you know but they're
pressured and I get it they're pressured
so I get it but I believe that's going
to change at the time you have daughters
if your daughter's called you and said
that somebody is doing to them what
they'll let what the allegations are
about you would you be okay with that
let me tell you stuff might be up in
that mother everything up I had to
believe myself but I yes if your
daughters came to you and said look this
guy is doing to me what the allegations
are against then I would have to arrest
myself out I did what I had to do you've
been very candid that you are a sexual
abuse survivor yourself you've talked
very candidly you were molested from the
ages of 7 to 13 14 how do you think that
has affected you it hasn't affected me
at all I mean yeah it affected me in
this way anything that I've been through
that or any struggles I've had in my
past has affected my music it has it
affected your behavior
absolutely not become at a stump you
know I know people they all were he was
abuse that's why he's doing that
no no no the experts will tell you this
most people who are abusers have been
abused but not all people that have been
abused go out and abuse others okay and
so that's why I say that is what they
know they didn't know right no yeah I
stand so that's right now I'm in love
not all I mean they're not all okay but
they also didn't say when you are Kelly
okay and you're famous and your name is
ringing
25 million times a day all over the
world okay of people trying to get money
from you okay and they're using your
past they're using the past allegations
the past case that he beat to link it
all to that okay they're using that when
you say that you need help do you think
you need to go to therapy have you been
to therapy absolutely at this point I'm
definitely talking about that about
going oh absolutely yeah you know it
seems like you know some could say you
might seem out of touch to a lot of
people what are you well I mean your
perception of the charges against you I
know it's your side and it's your story
but you have a different perception that
most of the world has about you know I
would think you you people have
perception people have their perception
I have truth do you think you're
invincible oh absolutely not
I just think I'm human well your tareka
don't Duncan joins us at the table
you've covered these allegations and the
stories against him you've talked to the
victim some of the victims and their
families how do you think this interview
is gonna resonate in the court of public
opinion in the corner in the adamant
about your issue and I think the fact
that you know first of all great job to
you and the crew that we're able to book
this interview because I don't think
anybody expected to hear from our Kelly
I didn't have a man over that magnitude
celebrity deciding to sit down while
he's actually facing felony charges that
could end him could land him in prison
for up to 70 years and he decided to
give his side of course we did want to
hear it but I think when you look at
social media and on Twitter he doesn't
have a lot
poor I think there are people who will
say oh you know this is what I'm saying
the girls were lying or what-have-you
but by and large the what I'm hearing
and what I'm seeing is not a lot of
people have sympathy for him and even
from some of the victims the alleged
victims jaronda pace she was featured in
that docu-series and said that she met
our Kelly after he was acquitted and
then started a sexual relationship with
him when she was 16 years old so she
said on Twitter I did not see our Kelly
I didn't see my abuser what I saw was a
man that needs help when you've been
doing wrong for decades she said and the
people around you make you feel that
your actions are right you tend to
believe that you're doing no wrong and
then we also got a statement from
sparkle sparkle is the artist that our
Kelly used to work with she was also
featured in the docking series she plays
a bigger role in this huge narrative
because she was one of the first to
speak out she's the one that identified
her needs as the one in that first video
where he was charged with child
pornography her niece was 13 14 at the
time right and she said this was the
niece of course he was acquitted she
didn't say it was heard the parents
didn't say it was her but Sparkle said
the interview is continued display of
Roberts entertain at all costs mentality
she said with arrogance and a lack of
accountability I'm praying for their
safe return back to their families in
reference to the girls I agree with what
jaronda said I I think he needs help I
think that as we were sitting there I
felt that he was really became very
emotional several times that wasn't just
you've seen some of the outbursts but he
became very very emotional
many many times during the interview and
I actually think that he needs help I
thought in some ways were we were seeing
a breakdown right before our eyes he
composed himself and came back because
he does want people to hear him but he
does think the world is out to get him
and everybody is lying and that's just
and I said after a while Robert went how
can everybody be lying except you
what makes you either so special or what
makes you so unlikable that all these
women would come out against you how and
let's remind everybody just how many
women have accused him of abuse and
misconduct well there were seven in that
docu-series but there were about 50
people in total who talked about things
that they may have seen
necessarily boost by him but there was a
young lady who said she claims she saw
him having sex with the Lea yeah he
didn't talk about that earlier the
artist who he allegedly married when she
was 15 years old and later passed away
but it was fascinating now that was a
remarkable interview and again I think
everyone is just so shocked that it went
on for so long I mean if you look at
prior interviews where he's left when it
goes too deep he gets up and he leaves
but you were able to keep him in that
chair and he did compose himself and he
continued as he said he said I've been
silent for too long while people were
saying all these things about me I want
people to hear from my own mouth right
in the end he said thank you for giving
me the platform to say this we even
asked you want to take a break do you
want some tissue no leave me alone just
let me talk and that's that is what we
did well of course we'll be waiting to
see what happens as this goes to trial
potentially because that is the opinion
that matters exactly it's not just
social media decide whether or not
there's enough evidence to the thing
that got to him the most those Jericka
was his relationship with his own
children yeah he came most emotional
when he kept talking about I want to see
my children I want to have a
relationship with my children there are
clearly issues with he with art Kelly
and his ex-wife Andrea which he says he
has the utmost respect for her because
she is a mother of his children but
that's what got to him the most talking
about his own show and it's worth noting
we likely wouldn't even be here having
this discussion if it wasn't for that
docu-series
we've been cooking for the past mostly
true yeah Thank You jurika